did my Umrah Oh you don't already you've
also four years ago your name is Deborah
honcho Deborah ham show I'm Sandy's
friend you know sandy pass right I think
it's okay I'm just another convert yeah
and I watch your show religiously
because I like the questions that you
ask thank you so this is a your friend
also she also accepted Islam well that's
a man what's his name sandy sandy
Sanford Oh
Stanford okay Stan Stanford yes you know
him he's also uh he's also from a Jewish
background who accepted Islam correct
yes so tell us now you are you're also
your mother father are Jewish yes my
mother and father my mother was born in
America my father was born in Poland he
was served in the Israeli army yeah okay
and you're from you're currently from us
you live in or you were born in Staten
Island New York
uh no I was born in Brooklyn Brooklyn
yeah okay so go ahead just an island I
got married this is a second marriage
for me I'm married my husband and we had
a little daughter she's grown up now
she's not so little anymore
I accepted Islam because I wanted to
share with my husband a beautiful Dean
of Islam and seven years ago we've been
married 20 how long were married 25
years 25 years so so I heard so some of
the things that you talked about that
you were stricken with emotional
difficulties in life yeah you know the
Russian anxiety like most Americans yeah
and and continued on from there
well I will tell you that Islam doesn't
solve old problems it gives you a manual
for dealing with the problems so I had
to get my mind straight my husband would
pray over me and I would pray but I
think the best thing to know is this is
a it's a human affliction so just open
up the book and be moderate so I learned
I learned when I was a little girl I
went to yeshiva
I prayed in in Hebrew so I always loved
God the one true God so as I grew up I
was searching and I found all kinds of
different things but I never found
anything like Islam except it brought me
back to my Jewish roots I have to say
mm-hmm well it's kind of strange isn't
it talk to us more about that when you
say it brought you back to your Jewish
Way I all the stories all the prophets
the only one that I I was missing was
Jesus Christ well though I wasn't
missing him because they used to tell me
I killed him so I didn't know him you
know I said well I can't know him
because I killed him but uh what I'm
saying is that it brought me back to my
roots because we pray the same way
except we don't do you know the we
meaning the Islam does a subdued but I
can tell you that I can speak perfect
Yiddish I can speak some Hebrew and I'm
telling you that I know for a fact that
it is almost identical it is an
identical belief except they do not
accept Muhammad sallallaahu a name is
sena yeah
so you dish for people that i don't know
what is either let me explain to you
what it is we have two types of jews
okay they're not sex okay we are arabic
jews we are used your pain i assume your
east-european
okay when you're east european you are
like a jew who speaks Yiddish which
means you speak German but it's written
in Hebrew if you were a Jew from a
Spanish bee
in country you would be speaking Ladino
so I'm askin Ozzy derivation and we we
used to like I don't know it's like all
the same but it's different I was
actually thinking about verse 49:13 I
think it is I woke up from a dream and
last night I said to myself you know
Dean I said to myself wait a minute how
come he made us different well it says
in the book it says that he made us
different male and female and he made us
into tribes so that we know each other
I said how we gonna know each other no
it doesn't mean we know each other it
means we have to know each other are we
gonna perish
that's what it means I think you're
talking about a verse oh yeah yep
from the from the verbatim from the
verbatim word of God Almighty the Quran
where God Almighty and saying that I've
made you into nations and tribes and yes
and the different colors and the
languages that we know he has yes
because no Arab is better than a
non-arab know black is bono white is
better than a black Muhammad the other
Muhammad no no no no I'm sorry
Ali Mohammed Ali was the best of oil
because you're talking about the
American the Muslim American hero
Muhammad Arlene yeah he was he loved
children and he didn't hate white people
yeah I'm not white because I'm you know
we come from the Holocaust so but I
thought it'd be interesting for your
viewers to know the ones who are
considering it that are Jewish don't be
afraid because most Arabs they don't
dislike Jews as much as they dislike
Zionism and you know we weren't Zionists
well our life but they drummed it into
us also you know I don't know if he's
wear hijab and I don't always speak the
way I should maybe I don't have their
table and yeah I'm old or whatever
but I want to give you a message and the
message is you want to be happy you want
to have a sisterhood we want to be I
mean just come and be with us no matter
what your religion is you know come and
share with us your religion let's hear
your side I guarantee you you're gonna
like what I tell you
there is a story about a Jewish man and
a Christian and a Muslim and they're
sitting having dinner and they're
sharing their face with each other you
know what they believe in the Jewish man
talks about how he believes in Moses
peace be upon him and then the Christian
he talks about how he he believes in
Moses also and then Christian but he
elevates him to the status of a God the
Muslim the Muslim comes along and since
and and we know that the Jewish they he
talks about how he he stops at Moses he
doesn't affirm Jesus as the Messiah
believe in him but then the Muslim comes
along and says that I we believe in in
Moses we believe in Jesus peace be upon
him not as a god or literal son of God
as the Messiah is the Messenger of God
who was sent by God calling people to
worship only the one God but we also
believe in the final messenger that came
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him and all the previous messengers
who came with that same message calling
to the pure monotheism to worship one
and only one God and to be morally
upright and this is the message that
resonated with you yeah it's a message
what really resonated with me is love
because I loved my husband okay and we
have difficult times you know cuz he's
Arabic and Arabs are special you hear
the Adhan now rang a limit let us hear
let us hear that hold on cause the
prayer for those who have never heard it
saying God is Almighty is the greatest
God Almighty is the greatest yes so yeah
this is a and you're going in your home
right now yeah because we're gonna have
the pitar right we're gonna have
it's Ramadan I mean Ramadan Kareem to
all our listeners a lot but I told you
his story but you know it's a difficult
one this is you just said God Almighty
is the greatest yes he is so this is
well alaikum Salam how are you so it's
very unique and it's very nice to meet
someone because Islam is a universal way
of life and now when there's many
misconceptions with you know all Muslims
hate Jews and all this other nonsense
you know but we try to clear that we're
seeing right now that we have a living
example you actually name Stanford also
who are in the program a few weeks ago
who's also Jewish who accepted Islam you
also Jewish background accepted the
Islam and this is we like to highlight
to show this to the world
oh it's wonderful I do have to say
something to you right I have a
wonderful share of his name
I gotta say she's in Ohio I need as you
saw we from Egypt a wonderful man we
have a convert group so if you want to
join us it's IC JC
but I'm not in Ohio I'm just telling you
he took my Shahada
I did my Umrah oh you don't know it
already you've also four years ago went
to UM Brian I'm so scared
oh my god mr. Dean I was so scared I
thought I was I didn't tell my husband
this I thought that but you know I slept
through a lot of it I have to say so I
have to go again but that lon knows my
heart right
[Music]
yeah you're gonna cry yeah you did a lot
of crying I was very emotional huh yeah
very emotion hello it's very merciful he
loves us and you know the more you give
I have a book it says if you love Allah
it's because you want to give and what
makes a man a thinking man happy is
giving because Allah gives what is Allah
who is Allah you try to get the 99 names
just get the 99 you you mentioned
something about Judaism is like a fog
Christianity very cloudy day and Islam
is the clear light of day poet and I I
wrote that because I felt that I was
coming out of the fog wait wait I found
Christianity did the darkness of
Christianity no what did I say and what
I forgot your I repeat it you said
Judaism is like a fog Christianity is
very cloudy a day Islam is the thing
loving people and the Jews do not accept
anybody okay and the Islam is like an
invitation like an open invitation a
wedding come on let's make a [ __ ]
let's make a you know let's make a match
look there are a lot of things I may not
agree with but you know if Allah said it
he said it I may not agree with it
sometimes because I don't understand it
all right it's a very interesting book
and I and I and I hope that you know me
and my girlfriend we want to we want to
spread the word together yeah there
might be some things now that we don't
understand like you said but we know
that God Almighty Allah and His perfect
wisdom everything that Islam is perfect
human beings are imperfect so now
anything that allows them all just so he
there's nothing that he revealed that's
in just for anybody it's a perfect
system but we just have a lot to learn
correct I mean look we have the Covey's
now right what is the message behind
Koba
I think people are getting it Allah
wants to tell us something he's trying
to tell us something and it's very loud
and clear be with your people stay home
read the Quran just love each other man
that's what it's LOM teaches me don't
look at somebody and get scared I have a
very like because of the Holocaust I
think it makes me very very upset why
people are so cruel to each other I mean
you man you have to watch those movies
too and you see the role Inga and you
say come on I mean come on look at Yemen
look at the kids I mean come on
I want to what can I say
Eddie what can I say brother Eddie would
or your family were they connected do
you have in your your your grandparents
or your parents were Holocaust survivors
my father's father was a very very wise
like streetwise you know and he knew how
to get his family out he wasn't rich
they went to Israel why because they
couldn't get to America so my mother
went with my grandmother to Israel and
they met there it was a love story and I
was conceived over there after marriage
and then they came back that's a whole
Megillah told story over there so he
came back with my father my father
mother didn't stay together long but
anyway what was I trying to say you
asked me a question
No No thank God yeah but but I feel it
deep in my soul because I you know I
come from those people I come very you
know but there's a lot of so people say
I said okay but there's a lot of
suffering in the world
look what the Jews do to the look what
the Zionist as the Palestinians me my
own daughter went to Israel she said ma
what's the what's going on here we'll
all pray one day guys at what's the name
the Wailing Wall know they call it the
Wailing Wall a katella Mahdavi I forgot
what they call it luck sir
I mean I know a lot I'm not bragging I'm
just saying from 68 years ago when a
little girl is praying to the one an
Almighty God
Bodie huh you know making the blessings
in the brothers what's a broker
it's a Baraka right and then coming I
mean it's a miracle don't you think yeah
so what what uh what what what advice
would you give for somebody out there
who's seeking to know the purpose of
life while they're here they hear a lot
of negative things associated with Islam
you know but they're seeking the truth
they're tuning in what advice would you
give them I would say first of all go to
a mosque don't be afraid I would also
say read you've got to read knowledge is
important and you know what if you can't
read or you're afraid the first step you
don't have to go near anybody just turn
on the TV watch the Dean show watch any
show that you like like I call you the
Islamic Joe Rogan you want to just talk
mail stuff you know what I'm talking
about you know what I mean everything so
you know guys and for women you know
it's clean our religion is a very clean
religion we do believe in separation so
just do yourself a favor we're not
different than you we want you to come
in you have your hint of faith what can
I tell them Dean I could tell them watch
the message it's a very good movie with
Anthony Quinn you can get it on YouTube
watch her to rule the module
what's the message the message that's a
good yeah that's a good start message
that's a good that's a good film yes
I'll send you some books
anyone will send you books we have to
listen you and I we have to give out the
message to the people and you've been
doing at the years I saw The Jerusalem
gangster that's I bought his book a
phenomenal man
or you saw that episode and that man let
me tell you I read his book and he's an
intelligent guy but he had a lot of
mistakes in that book a lot of Muslim he
said I kept it there purposely because I
want people to know where it came from I
know after a while it couldn't read it
was like driving me nuts but it was a
good book please people buy the book
this tells you that Islam has nothing to
do with Palestinians it has nothing to
do with terrorism the man was not a gang
Steve's is looking for love and trust me
some of the Arabs they can really pick
rough people but they're lovely they're
lovely lovely people so you know what
can I say thank you thank you so much
you can see you speaking from the heart
you know thank you so much it's a it's a
blessing you you made ombres you've
you've you chosen to to you know come to
Islam may Allah accept and have a
wonderful Ramadan Eid Mubarak was a
pleasure thank you sister thank you for
sharing thank you for your highlights of
your story and your experience Deborah
I'm so here on the Deen show yes
Salaam alaikum WA Rahmatullah